la terre compte près de 8 milliards
d'êtres humains ce qui veut dire qu'en
200 ans la population mondiale a été
multipliée par 8 avec le réchauffement
climatique quelle pression cela met sur
la planète 8 milliards de population ce
sera jamais trop sur la terre il s'agit
de trouver les bonnes opportunités pour
les populations ou qu'elles soient et
d'éviter les inégalités et de leur
permettre de bénéficier de leurs droits
pour Samuel le sage et sa conjointe
Anne-Marie Dubreuil qui ont 31 ans il
est hors de question d'avoir un enfant
si j'avais un enfant j'aurais
extrêmement de gêne dans les yeux en lui
disant ça va bien tout ça en sachant que
le monde court à la catastrophe
climatique en ce moment dans le monde
dans lequel on vit est-ce que ça fait du
sens pour moi mais on a décidé que non
il y a un an Samuel a subi une
vasectomie une prise de position pour
moi il y a quelque chose de un refus je
refuse une certaine société qui
par son idéologie dit tout va bien
maintenant le statut quo les enfants sa
plus belle chose qui puissent vous
arriver les enfants sont porteurs de
l'avenir j'en ai pas faut en avenir j'en
ai pas du tout le couple est conscient
qu'un enfant de moins sur terre ça ne
résoudra pas la crise climatique selon
la Banque mondiale l'empreinte carbone
des Canadiens est trois fois plus
importante que la moyenne mondiale bref
ce n'est pas tant le nombre d'êtres
humains mais plutôt le mode de vie des
Canadiens et des pays développés qui
posent problème selon la biologie de
l'Université néguil Catherine Podvin un
Canadien ça utilise environ 25 fois plus
d'énergie dans sa vie qu'un chinois les
grosses auto le climat nous aide pas
puis les distances nous aident pas mais
en dehors du climat et des distances et
notre mode de vie on est à vide de
grosses maisons de grosses voitures on
vit de plus en plus en banlieue tout le
monde veut faire des voyages à
l'extérieur même si la population
mondiale continue de s'accroître il
pourrait atteindre les 10 milliards
d'humains en 2050 le rythme ralentit
rien à voir avec le baby-boom des années
60 et l'élément positif dans tout ça
selon cette économiste c'est que les
populations augmentent surtout dans les
pays qui produisent moins de gaz à effet
de serre évidemment ça va dépendre de
comment ces pays-là
croient au niveau de leur économie puis
on voudrait également qu'il n'ait pas la
même trajectoire de croissance que nous
on a connu
Patrick bonnet le responsable de la
campagne climat énergie chez Greenpeace
Canada comprend les cours anxiété chez
certaines personnes qui décident de ne
pas avoir d'enfants mais il a fait un
choix différent il est aujourd'hui père
de trois enfants faut pas penser que le
passé est garant de l'avenir il y a une
jeune dame qui a commencé à faire une
journée de grève par semaine et ça s'est
transformé en un mouvement où il y a eu
des milliers de jeunes Greta à travers
la planète qui ont mobilisé dans leur
comté
selon lui les parents peuvent apprendre
à leurs enfants comment avoir
l'empreinte écologique la plus faible
c'est certain que les transports la
diminution de l'utilisation de
l'auto-solo c'est centrale on y arrivera
pas sur 10 nulle pas aussi notre
consommation de viande par exemple ou si
on ne dit pas la surconsommation en
général pensez au plastique à usage
unique pour le militant écologiste
chaque petit geste compte mais convient
que l'appui des gouvernements reste plus
que nécessaire pour renverser la vapeur
ici Gabriel pro Radio-Canada Montréal